since I started my channel in 2009 I've
been trying to bring more attention to
anime in fact my first review on my old
channel was for Hayao Miyazaki's Ponyo
Japanese animation has influenced our
culture since Astro Boy flew across
television screens or Speed Racer aired
in the afternoons on Cartoon Network
while this medium is a staple of
Japanese entertainment it took much
longer to gain recognition and
acceptance overseas but after Cartoon
Network's Toonami block introduced an
excited generation of kids to shows like
Sailor Moon Dragon Ball Z outlaw star
gundam wing and rurouni kenshin
what was once a niche medium began to
blossom into something bigger the story
of animes impact is a compelling one and
it's a tale I've always been interested
in largely because I'm part of the
generation that adopted it I perused the
anime aisles at comic shops or in
Blockbuster Video picking up dusty VHS
cases that hadn't been rented in years I
suffered through early horrendous
English dubs
and had the privilege of observing this
beloved art form eventually take a
well-deserved place in our popular
culture so I approached the fine folks
at mango media who helped publish my
first book the film buffs bucket list
with an idea originally I planned on
writing a book about anime I'd research
its history its appeal across a broad
spectrum of fans and eventually present
a well-rounded view of its impact on our
culture but one of animes most beautiful
aspects is that it speaks to each of us
differently my personal relationship
with anime will naturally differ from
the introvert who found her voice by
discussing her favorite show with a
fellow fan or the man who met his future
wife through their shared love of this
beautiful art so with the publishers
blessing I set out to find a group of
authors to share the writing duties with
me to reflect the many distinct stories
that come from discovering a love of
anime in the pages of anime impact I've
written many articles myself on various
shows and movies that mean a great deal
to me as well as an introduction and a
closing I've also edited the book
but what I'm most excited about is the
many voices included you'll hear from
Doug Walker Robert Walker and Malcolm
ray all from Channel awesome Tristan
gallant aka glass reflection mother's
basement
Alicia Malone Emma Fife I of soul
Adele drover Derek Padula a well-known
author of many dragonball books about
the fandom and culture comic book girl
19 young yang one of the creators of
pause and select an anime essay series
on YouTube Bryan ruff author of stray
dog of anime the films of Mamoru Oshii
the pedantic romantic
Melissa C Bennet white Mark Crilley
artists and writer of the mangas Brody's
ghost and Mickey Falls as well as hosts
of a very well-known how to draw channel
and even Ernest Cline author of ready
player one submitted an entry to the
book and there are even more writers in
those pages to discover also included
are some authors who aren't necessarily
known per se there are many talented
writers who've never been given the
opportunity to showcase their voices and
I'm so thrilled to be able to show those
voices in anime impact as well some of
the writers are nurses personal trainers
English as a second language teachers
data entry specialists and even software
engineers people who aren't known for
writing are included in this book as
with the film buffs bucket list the goal
here is not to simply pen another best
of list you don't need me for that one
quick internet search will cover you
there rather my goal is to highlight the
works that have moved us most the titles
included are almost all handpicked by
the various writers as ones they wanted
to discuss
you'll hear filmmakers describe how
anime has influenced their movies or how
a certain show helps someone get through
a day during one of life's rough patches
you'll read stories of personal
discovery many writers have detailed
their experiences that led to unearthing
a life-changing anime others have taken
a more analytical approach each writer
was encouraged
to express themselves authentically and
I believe their intimate expressions
have created something special this
isn't just a list of essential titles
it's a discussion of the true impact of
anime on multiple generations I am so
thankful for this opportunity and I hope
you enjoy reading anime impact as much
as myself and the other writers enjoyed
creating it the book releases on April
15th
and you can pre-order it at Amazon in
the description below it will also be
available in bookstores and online at
these retailers thank you so much for
your support over these years I am so
grateful for everything more updates
will come very soon including
information about a live book signing I
want to do to be able to meet some of
you guys and give you the book and talk
to you in person to let you know how
thankful I am for all these years of
support thank you very much guys and as
always if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]